بعد حوالي عام من الحرب يستغرب محلله فرن
بوليسي الغياب شبه التام لاي نقاش بين
السياسيين
وصانعي القرار حول عواقب الهزيمه على
روسيا الامر الذي تعتبره المجله امرا خطرا
بالنظر الى احتمال انهيار روسيا وتفكها
الجمع بين حرب فاشله في الخارج ونظام
الهاش في الداخل يزيد من احتماليه حدوث
نوع من الانهيار الداخلي بغض النظر اذا
كان هذا جيد ام سيء للغرب فهو نتيجه يجب
على صانعي السياسه الاستعداد لها تقول
نساء هناك سيناريوهات مختلفه مشاهدينا لما
قد يحدث في روسيا بعد ما تصبح لهزيمه في
اوكرانيا اكثر وضوحا على الارجح هو رحيل
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين من منصبه
يليه صراع شرس على السلطه بين القوميين
اليمنيين الذين يريدون مواصله الحرب
وتدمير تسلسل الهرمي السياسيه الحالي وبين
حركه شبه ديمقراطيه صاعده ملتزمه بانهاء
الحرب واصلاحه روسيا الوصول الى هذه
المرحله سيدعوا الروس الساقطين الى النزول
الى الشوارع ربما حتى بالسلاح ويشجع بعض
المناطق العرقيه غير الروسيه على اختيار
المزيد من الحكم الذاتي ترشح مشاهدينا فرن
البوليسي ان تظهر هذه النزاعات في
تتارستان والشيشان و داغستان وغيرها هذه
السيناريوهات التي تعتبر حلم منزل اوكران
وضع علمهم يمكن ان تكون كارثه عالميه بحسب
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الاسباب هذه
[موسيقى]